the biden administration now says that
federal law will take precedent over
state law when it comes to providing
mothers with abortion services if their
lives are at risk now yesterday the
department of health and human services
told hospitals they must provide such
services for emergency conditions like
ectopic pregnancies and complications of
pregnancy losses even in states where
abortion is banned with no exceptions at
the same time more men are taking action
themselves in the aftermath of roe v
wade turning to vasectomies the number
of google searches for the word
vasectomy peaked just one day after the
supreme court's ruling last month and
now doctors are saying that it's not
just searches more patients are asking
for the procedure
irl in real life manuel bojorquez is in
miami shores with more manny i'm going
to be watching this very closely good
morning
that's right good morning you know we
also spoke with a doctor who said the
way he found out about the supreme
court's decision that day is by the
sheer number of phone calls coming into
his clinic he said they tripled their
normal volume and the number of men
signing up for the procedure triple two
i just want to get a feel for why you
feel so confident that you're going to
be happy with your vasectomy decision
indefinitely from his office near tampa
urologist doug stein calls patients who
are under 30 or do not have children to
discuss whether they are 100 percent
sure they want a vasectomy a call he's
now making more often we generally see
about 12 percent in our practice men who
are child free
and then we generally see about 12
of men who are under the age of 30. but
the number of both
young and child free
nearly doubled the two doctor practice
performs six vasectomies an hour most
days some decisions not just made by men
but by families fifty percent of our
calls are from women i just need you to
plant science
twenty-seven-year-old thomas figueroa
says he and his girlfriend do not want
children so getting a vasectomy was
always on his mind i've always thought
about this decision
the supreme court did push me to finally
do it the procedure which blocks sperm
from entering semen is outpatient and
takes about 10 minutes with about a two
day recovery as opposed to a female
tubal ligation which is riskier and much
more invasive for figueroa this is also
about easing the burden on women who
have had their constitutional right to
abortion taken away and for those who
feel restrictions on birth control could
come next i feel for a lot of men
especially for myself that this is a way
where they're trying to protect their
girlfriend they're trying to protect
their partners they're trying to protect
their future partners in houston jordan
castro's post about getting a vasectomy
went viral he did it last fall after
texas passed a law banning abortion
after about six weeks of fertilization
really
try to put yourself in a woman's shoes i
really think i should
i should
take that into account and just take a
little bit more responsibility and while
vasectomies are reversible not all
reversals are successful all right very
good do you have any pain
that's something dr stein stresses to
his growing number of patients do you
see this as a trend that will continue
or just kind of a spike i think that
maybe where the spike is over and we're
tapering down a little bit but i think
we haven't tapered back down to pre-row
overturn numbers
in fact he says they are booked through
august and that's as far in advance as
they've ever been booked before vlad
all right manny thank you very much uh a
lot of cringing in the studio we all had
a reaction to that well i didn't realize
that you would be awake while the
procedure is actually happening that's i
thought you'd go under the knife even
though it's only ten under the you know
to sleep even though it's only 10
minutes but
no you know nate has talked about having
a vasectomy so i'm not telling tails out
of school he compared it to
cutting off his sprinkler system
which i thought was a really good way to
say it he said that when he went in for
the procedure for a consultation he
ended up getting it that same day
because it was so simple so the laws
must be different in new jersey because
i've been i talked to nate about it i
talked to other friends about it uh and
i i there's a waiting uh period in new
york you have to wait 30 days and then
have to get it within a six-month window
it's easier to buy a gun than it is to
get a vasectomy in new york state but my
two questions were going into it is the
fun stuff still fun and the doctor was
like yeah
[Laughter]
what's a fun stuff yeah tell us about
that
this tender hour
okay and they said yes and they said yes
rock and roll yeah and then and like
your inner caveman does he still feel
like he's there like you still feel a
little sense of virility this is a real
thing for guys yeah and and nate says
yes and other friends i've talked to
have said yes so i'm all in if there
were for the waiting period i'd do it
today also you would yeah if they had
like a mobile van outside right now why
don't they have the mobile van the
mobile you would you would do it totally
i don't know it was interesting to see
all the men in the studio cringe maxi
goes how come he's not knocked out
i'm surprised that he's just looking at
it i know that was the weird thing
because the shot of the camera was like
he's like this he's like okay what's
going on down there so it's not pain i
guess it's not that painful either
oh boy right i i don't know
[Laughter]
all right let me grab this uh but it is
interesting that no more men are
choosing to do this now yes
that was the small thing compared to in
the wake of this decision